Alex in 94 I remember to cover.
So we had divided,
you know,
had the White House in the hands of Bill
Clinton and then congress in the hands
of Newt Gingrich.
Um,
but yes,
I certainly think that all of them,
the trends at the moment for a
democratic sweep in November,
I don't think we should take anything
for granted because John McCain is still
a very,
very much seen in the media as the John
Mccain of 2000 and not the John Mccain
of 2008.
Um,
but nevertheless,
that is definitely very likely.
And therefore,
if Lou real leadership is exercise is a
very good chance that we could end up
with finally having some from low
universal health care insurance,
which is desperately needed in this
country for the 7 million people are
uninsured.
And,
um,
also that we would be able to move
closer to energy independence and bring
the truth,
Tom from Iraq,
that,
that I thing is,
has to be our number one action.